اكد مدير شؤون الاونر في قطاع غزه توماس
وايت ان قافله مساعدات غذائيه كانت تنتظر
لانتقاله الى شمال غزه تعرضت لقصف البحريه
الاسرائيليه واضاف المسؤول ان القصف لم
يخلف اي اصابات في طاقم قافله
الاغاثه من رفح ينضم الينا مراسل الجزيره
هشام زقوت هشام اخر التطورات هذا الصباح
في
غزه سهام اخر التطورات هي استمرار للقصف
الاسرائيلي والقصف الاسرائيلي مركز منذ
عده اسابيع على مدينه خانيونس وبالتحديد
في محيط مستشفى ناصر وايضا في محيط مستشفى
الامل الذي سمحت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
بانشاء ممر امن وخروج عدد من النازحين من
هذا المستشفى خلال الساعات مساء اليوم
مساء امس القصف الاسرائيلي لكن رغم هذا
الممر الانساني وهذه العمليه الا ان القصف
الاسرائيلي كان مركزا على حي الامن وفي
محيط هذا المستشفى ايضا اشت شعلت النيران
في محيط مستشفى ناصر بعد ان قصف الجيش
الاسرائيلي منزلا بالقرب من هذا المستشفى
وتطايرت الشداء الى الساحه الخارجيه
لمستشفى ناصر الذي ما زال محاصرا ويتواجد
فيه عشرات من النازحين ومئات من المرضى
والطاقم الطبي المتواجد في المستشفى والذي
يصر على البقاء في هذا المستشفى لتقديم
الرعايه الصحيه لمن يصل من او لمن يستطيع
الوصول من المصابين والجرحى الى هذا
المستشفى بفعل استمرار الحصار الاسرائيلي
وبفعل باستمرار القصف الاسرائيلي على محيط
هذا المستشفى القصف الاسرائيلي ايضا مستمر
ومتواصل على المناطق الحدوديه ما بين
مدينه رفح وما بين مدينه خان يونس والقصف
في تلك المنطقه ربما منذ يومين على الاقل
يشهد عنفا اكبر احزمه ناريه تنفذها
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه في تلك
المنطقه ايضا المناطق الشرقيه لمدينه رفح
باتت تتعرض يوميا الى قصف اسرائيلي من قبل
الطائرات الحربيه وكذلك من قبل المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه التي تواصل قصف تلك المناطق
بال القذائف من قبل الدبابات والاليات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه المتمركزه على
الحدود الشرقيه في تلك المناطق بالاضافه
الى ان القصف الاسرائيلي على تلك المناطق
سواء في حي السلام او في حي الجنينه وهي
في المناطق الشرقيه لمدينه رفح تستهدف في
جلها منازل مدنيه فلسطينيه ايضا المنطقه
الحدوديه على في مدينه رفح ما بين مصر
وقطاع غزه تتعرض ما بين يوم واخر الى قصف
من الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه وهذا
القصف يتز بكل تاكيد مع التصريحات
الاسرائيليه خاصه لوزير الحرب الاسرائيلي
الذي يتحدث عن مدينه رفح وان العمليه
القادمه هي ستكون في مدينه رفح وبالتالي
القصف يشتد على هذه المدينه في ظل تحليق
مدي في ظل تحليق مكثف لطائرات حربيه
اسرائيليه وايضا للطائرات الاستطلاعيه
التي تكثف من طلعاتها في سماء مدينه رفح
القصف ايضا مستمر وربما بات اكثر عنفا في
مدينه غزه خاصه في المناطق الغربيه لمدينه
غزه سمع دوي انفجارات عنيفه في تلك
المنطقه منطقه ونحن نتحدث عن منطقه
الميناء ومنطقه دوار انصار دوار الماليه
هذه المناطق الغربيه لمدينه غزه حي الرمال
الجنوبي ومنطقه الميناء هذه المناطق باتت
تتعرض الى قصف عنيف من الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه وكذلك من المدفعيه لكن سمع
دوي انفجارات ناجمه على ما يبدو عن نسف
الجيش الاسرائيلي لعدد من المنازل في تلك
المناطق ايضا يسمع اصوات اطلاق نار على ما
يبدو انها ناجمه من طائرات استطلاعيه او
الطائرات الكواد كابتر اسرائيليه التي
تطلق النار على المواطنين في تلك المناطق
ايضا هناك قناصه يعتلون اسطح المنازل
والمنازل المرتفعه في مدينه غزه ويطلقون
النار على المواطنين في تلك المنطقه
والذين يحاولون الهروب من تلك المناطق
التي تتعرض الى القصف الاكثر كثافه الى
مناطق في شرق مدينه غزه وربما تكون اقل
عرضه للقصف الاسرائيلي خاصه ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي يركز قصفه وعمليته البريه منذ
عده ايام في مدينه غزه في المناطق الغربيه
وفي محيط مستشفى الشفاء وبالتالي القصف
الاسرائيلي يتركز في تلك المناطق لكن ايضا
الاوضاع الانسانيه صعبه للغايه في مدينه
رفح بعيدا عن الاوضاع الميدانيه زار مدينه
رفح ضيف ثقيل على قلوب السكان والنازحين
على وجه الخصوص وهي الامطار والاحوال
الجويه السيئه التي باتت تزور مناطق رفح و
وجنوب قطاع غزه خلال الايام الماضيه ضرب
عده منخفضات جويه هذه المناطق وبالتالي
تؤثر بشكل كبير
وتؤثر بشكل سيء على النازحين الفلسطينيين
الذين تغرق مياه الامطار خيامهم وتقتلع
الرياح هذه الخيام بالاضافه الى ان
الاوضاع كارثيه بشكل كبير في هذه المدينه
المكتظه والتي يتجمع فيها النازحون
الفلسطينيون فهم يعانون من جراء استمرار
القصف الاسرائيلي ومن جراء هذه الاحوال
الجويه السيئه ومن جراء نقص المواد
التموينيه وكل مقومات الحياه في هذه
المدينه التي باتت تفتقد الى كل شيء من
جراء استمرار الحصار الاسرائيلي واستمرار
ادخال مساعدات شحيحه الى قطاع غزه
بالاضافه الى ه ان هذه الاحوال الجويه
السيئه تعيق التدفئه وبكل تاكيد يعيش
الاطفال على وجه الخصوص والنساء اوضاعا
صعبه من جراء استمرار هذه الاوضاع الجويه
شكرا لك هشام زقوت مراسل الجزيره كنت معنا
من رفح و